bah
gad elmaleh
gal elmaleh mesdames messieurs bien
alors garde attention ap
alors votre spectacle la vie normale
donc en tournée en france ont fait la
promo lagat d'un anglais semblent hélas
au moment où décolle pas parce que c'est
un bond important fermement importante
ouvre donc la tournée jusqu'au 15
décembre
après il y aura l'olympia du 30 janvier
ou en février à la même époque sheeran
avait acheté le dvd
ça s'appelle une vie normale mise en
scène d'isabelle nanty
je vous demande votre spectacle parce
que j'ai fait la même chose avec
caroline donc j'ai l'habitude
donc tous les personnages de galles et
le mal et sont inspirés par de vrais
individus gaz hellman et notent tout
tout tout tout des petits bouts de
phrases sur des petits calepins et il
fait à la fin un ramassis de tout ce
qu'il a vu c'est comme un oiseau qui les
saisir des petites brindilles un peu
partout et qu'elle a faim construit un
nid sony c'est le spectacle de gad
elmaleh c'est la vie dans la main
voilà alors par exemple gagné le mal et
je vous pose une question très sérieuse
vous êtes au lit avec votre fiancée ont
du goût de fiancés
on dit pas le nom non non non non je
sais moi tout cela didier sandre nom
serait dj sand c'est fini donc vous êtes
vous êtes au lit avec votre fiancée
ouais
et puis soudain vous avez une idée de
sketches way basket génial elle est en
train de vous embrasser
qu'est ce que vous faites vous continuez
à l'embrasser vous vous lever pour aller
noté l'idée de sketches mais d'abord je
pense très très peur aux sketches ouais
et puis j'essaie de j'essaye de faire un
petit peu décès temporisé quoi de penser
à un truc et puis j'y vais quoi vous y
allez juste tellement professionnel que
même quand même j'espère que l'idée sans
la peur que le truc non même quand vous
êtes avec vous avez noté l'idée de ce
qu'avait fait ça non je suis maintenant
je voulais dire c'est que je suis jamais
au lit avec cette finance et donc pas
les assesseurs
je ne peux pas je trouve ça extrêmement
malpolis kedia [ __ ] j'ai une super
idée de répliques faut être à ce qu'on
aime parce qu'on fait je veux dire très
près ce qu'on voulait c'est le minimum
oui alors gad elmaleh j'ai entendu
hassan et banquets ce qu'est ce qu'ils
font c'est ça faudrait savoir à quelle
position risque sa folie c'est de rester
rica déposition elle peut pas s'en
apercevoir tu n'as que je fais un
calepin derrière la tête bien alors gad
vous dites je continue à vendre votre
spectacle
jusque là tout va bien vous dit en
parlant de vos personnages
c'est comme si j'avais une troupe et que
je provoque et chaque comédien pascal
personnages sont récurrents on les
retrouve de spectacle en spectacle
ouais ouais ça va jusque là non ouais
c'est vrai et puis oui je peux dire que
oui oui c'est ce qui m'amuse en viennent
à dire que oui du tout il peut penser
plus à la bombe à regarder